Next question, what are if de-glycerized liquorice, DGL, is okay to take while on PPI's?
So, PPI is a protein pump inhibitor. If you're on a PPI, pretty much guaranteed U.M.H.
by law. So, why did you go on a PPI? Well, because I had reflux and all sorts of reflux and my doctor
said that I should just go on a PPI because I could get some, I could get the soft agile
etcheted. I could end up with soft agile cancer. Tell you, PPI is like poison, you know, I'm sorry.
It's there's some drugs that are like, you could be on the rest of your life. It is probably going
to have no ill effects, be it on a centroid or something like that. Really, you tolerate it. Well,
you're not going to have any issues with that. Ever. It's a good drug. Be it on a PPI, bad drug.
Never was a good drug. It was, you realize steam of this day, it was always supposed to be used
for like 21 days, I think, back to them. But people have PPI's for years horrible for you. You want to
end up with, I mean, you could be on a PPI for just a sharp ear type and you're going to end up with H,
with H. Pylory. Or more realistically, because you went on a PPI, it was because you have,
you had a decreased H.C.L. and process quite possibly H. Pylory. So, I can't legally tell you to go
off a PPI. You need to deal with that with your prescribed doctor, but you need to deal with the
reason why. This is another, you said, the other thing that I held in this course is, you know,
you just give a person the drug, take care of the symptoms. It's just to me that's not the practice
and that is the practice of current medicine. That's not the practice of health care. It was giving
this drug to make the symptoms go away. Well, that'd be great. You know, that's like hitting your
head with a hammer and I'm going to give you an aspect so the pain goes away but to keep your head
with the hammer. Okay, that's kind of what's going on with that. So I hate to be mean, but I need to be
sometimes, that's just wrong, but I don't want to be mean to the person who's taking the PPI. You
don't know, but you need to learn. So, go to our website, look up our blogs for H.Pylory, H.C.L.
Look at the videos on that. I have a bunch of videos on our course on that as well.